uh let's see where do we want to go next
let's try let's go north of the border
let's go to alex from quebec
hi david can you hear me yes i can bian
venue
merci beaucoup i'm actually a first time
caller and
uh
before the pandemic in quebec the pro
the government had promised electoral
reform
away from first pass the post and
into a mixed member proportional
representation system sure but
among the advocates of electoral reform
there was a big debate between
those who wanted proportional
representation and those who preferred
uh well a
preferential voting system
justin trudeau actually was
more of an advocate of the second option
while the provincial government
preferred the first option
and i was just wondering uh what was
your preference between the two well i
you know i i always hesitate to weigh in
specifically about
questions in front of other countries
because i just don't feel as as if i'm
as well informed as i could be or should
be really to be commenting
but i've talked over the years about a
number of different
reforms to how we do our elections that
i would welcome
i would love a proportional
representation system big picture
because it could be a way for third
parties to make inroads in the united
states the risk of course is you get
five percent white supremacists or
something crazy and that's something
that that would have to be dealt with
and we would have to think about that
but i think proportional representation
especially in the us where this
two-party duopoly is a complete and
total mess would be an interesting thing
switching away from first past the post
to something like single transferable
vote or one of the many different ranked
choice voting systems that don't have
some of the problems that we've
identified in a few of the systems would
also be very much welcome a combination
of the two is something that i would be
open to i welcome that uh and in the u.s
i've talked about a lot you know in the
context of canada it seems more
appropriate to ask someone who's been
following the canadian discussion
well uh
in my honest opinion yes uh
everyone just advocates for the reform
that advantages them generally so for
example
yeah justin trudeau leads a centrist
party so of course he will prefer a
preferential voting system because if he
ends up against the right-wing
candidates he'll get the left-wing vote
and if he ends up against the left-wing
candidates he'll get the right-wing vote
whereas in quebec where the main issue
has been
nationalists not in the sense of like
white nationalists as in america but
nationalist as in wanting more autonomy
for the province wanting to protect the
french language and so on of course uh
yeah usually these parties have split
the vote between
left and right wing nationalists
allowing for
well parties who aren't that to
win more seats than they should have
and so quebec nationalists of course
prefer a proportional voting system
to
uh increase their representation yeah on
that on that front what what are the
rules right now in terms of the signage
in quebec is it that they the signs have
to be only in french or it has to be
french first and larger
uh well
in the 70s they tried to make it only in
french
and the supreme court of canada said
you're not allowed to do that that's
infringing on freedom of speech okay and
so today it's
predominantly french that means you can
put it in english
but uh the font has to be smaller than
in french understood i think
i think there's an exception in native
communities where
you are allowed to have signages only in
like inuit or euron or stuff like that
because yeah we want to protect french
but we don't want to like
end native languages
day-to-day
what's the how much french versus
english are you speaking is it 90-10 is
it
i almost
don't well i live in a rural region so
far away from
uh montreal where in montreal you need
english yes but
outside of that
you don't really need to i only learned
to speak english at 14. okay so
it really wasn't a necessity in my
day-to-day life yeah understood
understood
all right very good at fascinating to
hear about what's going on in quebec i
appreciate the call
all right thank you david all right
thank you
um
really great topics today really really
great topics let's speak to
oh i don't know how about
um
is this is this jake from massachusetts
hold on is it oh no it's do not call on
did not want me to call on sorry wow i
apologize somebody was just
they left the note saying don't call on
me and it it just looked so interesting
that i had to go with it let's go to
michael from berlin michael you're on
the air
hey david yes great to hear from you
pleasure um actually berlin new jersey
oh i don't
you do have an accent but it's a jersey
accent
yes yes yes thank you i visited germany
13 times though
because my
parents are from austria
uh so i'm a first generation australian
american now let me let me inquire about
that you went to germany 13 times
because your parents are from austria
why not go to austin
i'm sorry uh to clarify frankfurt
airport went from frankfurt to uh vienna
austria got it and uh so that was about
13 times uh through frankfurt got it
uh so i'm a little nervous this is the
first time i've ever called any show
you're doing great so far uh this is
actually on my bucket list so i
and that that's one of the things
what was on your bucket list oh i i
don't i don't have any i don't ever
think about the in those terms
unfortunately
i couldn't yeah i don't have a bucket
list
okay um well my bucket i just wanted to
give an example my bucket list would be
to travel the united states i'm into
endurance events and i would love to go
for a long distance bike tour
of the us and just meeting people and
discussing um
you know
meeting with different people and
talking about uh you know other things
local things uh you know just learning
learning from different cultures in the
us and maybe talk about democracy how we
can help our uh our democracy uh get
along because people don't understand
the process of just getting involved in
local politics absolutely that seems
like a worthy thing
yeah well i mean i need to leave a bab
since then that will take me like a
month or a couple months to do but oh
yeah i would set aside some time for
that
yeah i'd like to shout out to uh eggbert
as well who was from vienna he was a
caller and he hasn't called in for a
while and i've really enjoyed his uh
his uh
you know when he called in
all right very good shout out to eggbert
from austria i so appreciate the call